[Music]
dota has given me everything
that almost everything that i i have
materially it's given me a bunch of
friends
it's giving me so much he's also taking
a lot from me
oh gee eliminated on day number two
a ti-6 falling short of what you you're
aiming for in terms of placement
it's been a very harsh lesson but it's
always been one that i've been very
grateful for at the end it's just once
it hits
it always sucks this is a bitter pill to
swallow
for og for their fans there's no way
that
it's gonna be smooth people are probably
flaming him saying why why hotel didn't
carry my game guys why
why no-till did not carry og why did he
fail me again
there's no way that everything is going
to work out the way you think it will
why did you leave og the team hasn't
worked for a long time
like we kind of hit a dead end and i
want to win and i want to do it with
teammates i believe in
this was probably the shittiest moment
ever
if you're willing to work on these
challenges and you're willing to
overcome them you can
you can probably get the same feelings
that i've gotten which is
the feeling of great accomplishments
what against evil geniuses
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you've heard of og you know how a ragtag
group of discards
cinderellaed their way to not one but
two
of the biggest wins in the history of
esports how a pub star
a quitter a coach and a comedian
defied every conceivable expectation
and made
[Applause]
and history then there's the
long-suffering sweetheart who made it
all happen
the heart and soul of og the god in
whose
image it was created the flower the
rainbow
the river the big daddy himself
[Music]
johann sunstein the feisty adorable
little viking you know
as no tail was born and raised in the
esports powerhouse that is denmark
like a lot of dota greats he got his
start in heroes of new worth where
at the age of 15 he met his future best
friend and brother in arms
fly it feels it feels great winning
winning for a fourth time
it was a bit easy but but it was a great
it was really great man
what can i say together fly and no tail
took
han by storm once that scene began to
die down
they transitioned to dota 2 where they
set their sights
on a new challenge the biggest event
esports had
ever seen the international 2013
let's just say no-till was confident i'm
a great guy
like best as they get maybe a little too
confident double kill for mushy buyback
by doxia flyback by the end
but he is destroying triple ultra
and he will take the top racks and gg
comes out fnatic have been unlimited by
the malaysians orange
will advance themselves forward
unfortunately
fly and no-till never managed to cement
themselves as the kings of this new game
like they wanted
unable to find a group of truly
like-minded players
ones who valued loyalty and synergy over
raw individualistic talent they spent
years hovering
just below the top tier here with no
tail this tournament
you know it didn't go the way you guys
wanted it to go what uh
what do you think the reasons were um
all in all i think there's
been a bunch of things coming to this
disappointing result and
there's not so much we could have done
about it i think we did try our best
still
somehow they'd always find themselves at
the butt end of a disappointment
a disbanding or a kick team secret we we
did feel like a super team
but then there was this starladder
tournament and it's on to the throne
they got secret by the jugular and they
take
we ended up losing and that hit was
really hard
and after that i kind of saw it coming
but just months to the next ti
fly and no-tell found themselves kicked
from the very team they had just joined
the crazy thing is that more than
perhaps any other player
the community loved no tail he was
funny out of all the things you could
have decided to call yourself why a big
daddy yes i feel like big daddy do you
yeah fiery give me your battle roar
[Laughter]
and above all friendly at the end of the
day
no matter where you were from or who you
cheered for
it was hard not to love this little
[ __ ] my biggest inspiration
is cesar milan the dog whisperer a lot
of people laugh when i say it because
it is kind of a funny nickname that he
has but then again people left for the
one of my nicknames so we got that in
common what nickname do people laugh out
of yours
big daddy everyone wanted nothing but
the best for no tail
to see him win the big one unfortunately
it just didn't seem to be in the cards
when i
picked him up last year after ti the
first thing he told me
that i make my decision next year i will
be a part of the finance
sorry it's very rough because it is
there's so much built towards this no
matter how how much i try to look away
from that
every year is the biggest tournament in
esports it's made out to be such a big
thing
falling short of what you you're aiming
for in terms of placement
um has been a it's been a very harsh
lesson but it's always been
one that i've been very grateful for at
the end it's just once it hits it always
sucks
it felt as if he and fly were being
systematically screwed over by the
esport they adored
as if no roster could ever be what they
really
wanted a team that wasn't just a
business
but a group of friends a family
it can bring out the worst in people and
it forces you to be a good teammate
because it's a team game you only
succeed together and you lose together
if you're not a good teammate but you're
a great
player you're probably not going to get
very far vice versa
so they said [ __ ] it and founded their
own
organization oh gee big idea behind og
is a mindset of friendship
but also want to win we just want to do
things right
like do things our way what did it stand
for you ask
well as it turns out a lot of things
or nothing what does og stand for huh
some people say orangutan ganja i say i
don't [ __ ] know
it wasn't exactly clear what og was
supposed to signify
but it embodied an obvious attitude
empathy
comes with it if you're if you're by
nature uh
not somebody who's very empathic then
you gotta you gotta learn it which is a
great thing like learning empathy is
i believe like very good for all people
but dota kind of forces you to do it if
you don't do it
you're most likely gonna run into some
trouble in a team and it's
maybe gonna lose you this game is going
to lose your disqualifier you're not
going to get what you want and you're
going to sit there like
why didn't it work by prioritizing
confidence and camaraderie over
results fly and no tail built a
juggernaut from the ground up
one that ironically solidified itself as
the most consistently accomplished
roster dota has
ever seen oh gee i've got it they've got
the teaching out from secret
ot they fight all the way through the
lower bracket
and will be cleaned the champions of the
first ever
dota 2 major live here in frankfurt
trump will pop the bkb but they beat
down father they go
scepter to point defensively the bear
will fall the heroes next
oh gee are doing it liquid they can't
withstand the punishment
oh gee are the manila major champions
and gg is called
your champions rog
they've won three majors it's an
incredible theme
catch out lil the rocks will drop but
they just don't have the damage to repel
rg
vernon's pro collet gg og will be
claimed
four time dough to two major winners
here at kiev
the problem is that despite obliterating
the competition
all throughout the year og couldn't
close when it mattered most
i i don't think anybody ever lost a ti
and went out with a smile
that probably isn't the case but it's
you know it's a big slap in the face
for two years straight they failed to do
the one thing that
every dota player dreams of no tail more
than most
i don't have the answer to like how you
come into ti
and you know you're gonna the favorite
as a favorite and then still win
i think it's incredibly hard a lot of
things don't go your way and a lot of
things are against you
so yeah i mean to be honest i don't know
some people touted og as a sinking ship
but its two helmsmen stuck it out sure
their results outside of ti
were tapering off and no tail was
humiliating himself as a carry player
but this was fly in no tail brothers who
in spite of their recent failings and
frustrations
shared an unbreakable bond
at least that's what everyone thought
it's
raining it's thunder outside it's like
electricity is in the air
[Music]
and uh well we just got called into a
room
and i learned that the two players are
leaving
and one of them's my best friend fly in
s4's departure
quite literally tore og apart it felt
like an impossible betrayal the likes of
which dota
even esports at large had never seen
as for leaving sure i can understand
that
but fly leaving og
he's not just the captain he owns part
of the team
his girlfriend is the manager of the
team
it would tear the team apart if he would
leave
with only a handful of months until ti-8
it looked like o.g
were done its pieces could still land on
their feet
seb could always coach somewhere and
jerax was still revered as a top tier
support
but not no tail this sanki too tanky he
gets out of it no tail
is dead eleven comes back in they want
to try and go for this no-till kill jump
forward for lana he finds the impale
oh lose no tail he's not got buy back on
the lone druid
of the og players who'd been left behind
no tail was undoubtedly in the worst
spot
the public perception was that fly had
done most of the heavy lifting
he'd been the captain the drafter he
boasted a brain as big as his biceps
and the community was sure that no tail
would flounder without him
i always thought me and tal something so
strong how can it break
this was probably the shittiest moment
ever
[Music]
as far as anyone could tell no tail was
washed
i always believe that the hardest
choices in lives are the right ones
the ones that are easy are usually the
wrong ones and
in this case there was only one right
choice and it was the hardest one by far
was to rebuild so forming a team
three months before ti and having a shot
at winning ti no
not happening hell-bent on making it to
the international
no-till transitioned back to support put
seven as og's offlaner and enlisted the
help of
pretty much the only other top tier
talents he could get his hands on
a quiet unproven pub star named thompson
and og's former mid laning marauder
anna the atmosphere over the last month
like since we started
started with a new roster and started
the ti bloodbath it's been very good
it's been very fun to play it's been
very light everybody is
very passionate everybody gets to kind
of show what they want to in the games
at least that's why i feel i'm
really aiming for that that everybody
gets to
you know do do what they do best in the
game and do what they want to do
and at the moment the atmosphere is
really good very light
we're having fun somehow some way
they traversed the open and regional
qualifiers to make it into
what was being hailed as the most
competitive international
ever this year i think our chances are
actually better than they've ever been
that's that's my personal gut feeling
touted as being the weakest of the 18
teams the community was floored when og
managed to squeeze their way into the
upper bracket
they were even more surprised when after
sauntering their way out onto the main
stage
they didn't just win they went ham
whatever pressure or negative things
whatever goes on
once the game starts you're kind of
sucked into it like everything else just
goes away with the bkb
out punching people down they find two
kills that's gg
oh gee on in the upper bracket
no tail ecstatic with this
victory moving into the top six for o.g
what was already a miraculous run should
have and
probably would have ended right there
had it not been for the fire sparked by
og's next opponent
as fate would have it no-till's next
adversary
was none other than evil geniuses the
very
roster fly abandoned him for why did you
leave og
the team hasn't worked for a long time
and i can say personally that i lost a
lot of motivation
when the whole situation arised where i
could
join eg i felt a new surge of motivation
where i felt like this is really a team
i could win with
as opposed to the previous team where i
felt like we kind of hit a dead end and
i want to win and i want to do it with
teammates i believe in
any other series any other matchup
there's a good chance that og would have
rolled over
but not this one they finally uh
they're gonna find this for they're
gonna find fly as well gigi
is called a game one
in a series where i think a lot of
people have expected to see something
quite
fantastic from eg oh gee they absolutely
crush it
after a visceral bloodbath
no tail came out on top oh gee
looking to close things up they're onto
the agent they're beating it down at a
pace that
you can't defend
[Applause]
the series he'd exercised his demons on
the main stage of the international
and you could feel it
from that point on all og had to do
was the impossible og are going for the
tier fours
challenges their defense they will be up
in just a second the fortification
it buys time the hex is there from
chalice but now here comes anna he's on
the front lines jirax
leaping forward all he has to do is
create space for og to do it
to get to the grand final of t.i.a
tip him up him over the lead comes
forward they've got the control
x nova he'll go down this is the game
lgd has nothing left
oh g have done it
by rallying around the force of nature
that was no tail og were able to string
together a series of
bat [ __ ] crazy comebacks that landed
them in their first ever ti final
it was the day no-till had been waiting
for his entire career
i strongly believe that if i woke up a
morning and i had to play the ti final i
would play the best order of my life
and that's all that would matter to me
if i played my very best
[Music]
nothing else would matter and he did
potentially unlikely to save him as
hannah
surely wants to steal jason indeed
rushes forward there's jacks with the
devil he's got the snowball
to dodge the spirit lance at least but
fy very low
actually gets taken down there right the
blast from no-till saturn tormented
just not for very long this has the
damage they're on top of jared
somness gets the triple kill maybe even
more zana
now all alone no tails trying to come
across to help him turning towards nova
he's stuck in there with him as anna
will possibly find out what he does
he's gonna have doppelganger back up in
a second but the blood right is it there
in time it's not
doppelgangers back up he could jump out
looks towards chalice spirit alliance
finishes charlie sharp gets another
zomnis did
find no tail but anna's still going
can't stop the skill of the double gang
is there
anna trying to factor brush himself away
for soreness it will change the diffuser
blade on some summer fy
with the shot jumps it igloo into the
back side of anna
finally it was starting to look as if
og's free-spirited
shat wheeling rise to the top was coming
to an end
but in typical og fashion right as all
looked to be lost they rallied as the
buyback for jericho's comes in
he's healing anna back up that buyback
could set them up for the killer next
over the coal snap
down onto the atrocity they find him
he's out of banner he's starting to
shift into the straight but he's
surrounded
oh gee can they find them all they can
oh gee are still in the game slowly but
surely og
crawled their way back into a series
that they were never supposed to win
time and time again they stayed cool
adam can you do it here is it
he gets the goal of his lifetime
and persevered and they're all up i'm
just going to take no fight
just a slow fight in their basement
anna says he's done with this he wants
to end this game
until finally they were doing the one
thing that no tail had
always dreamed of as oh gee
from sam gets themselves another they're
on to the agent
oh gee
g
battled their way to what is almost
inarguably the single most miraculous
tournament victory
ever it was beautiful unforgettable
and undeniably well deserved but it was
a fluke
something that could never ever be
repeated or so we thought
one year after their unthinkable run at
ti-8
og returned to the international as an
unknown quantity
they'd taken much of the year off using
it as an opportunity to relax and
recuperate
the expectation was that having already
done the impossible
their fire had been quelled why should
you become weaker from doing this once
you can stamp it again because you're
satisfied with yourself because you're
satisfied so you're weak now
you had this infinite source of
motivation no it's not there anymore
you know but the way i see it is that
it's still there
you just chose to let it go og had an
unshakable faith in themselves
but no player never mind a team had
ever racked up two ti titles so why is
it
that winning two ti's has been so
difficult
thus far well it hasn't been that
difficult for us so far
we're not there
we'll let you know after ti9 it seemed
to go without saying that if anyone was
going to do it it sure as [ __ ] wasn't
going to be a
one in a million underdog like og nobody
took their silly
self-confidence seriously but as it
turns out
the community was wrong to underestimate
og
just like the first time he's the man
that's going going
going into the fountain once again bathe
and the glory of the radiance
thompson he just does not give a crap
anna will give all the life
this is just fountain farming gj
okay the difference is that
this time around o.g were bullies
they gave zero shits had nothing to lose
and played like it
and this would be a matter on the tony
now guess three bottle ruin charges up
so fly they start with the avalanche
steps moved over as well flight
he can get one punch in he ain't no one
punch man
he very clearly placed the no-till flag
was staring him in the eyes when he died
in a near perfect recreation of the
previous year's run
og steamrolled their way through the
upper bracket
but rg they will push
forward to the winners bracket final
repeating the history of ti8 to winning
eg in this semi-final two
now the physical damage will overrun the
throne in psg lgd
and at three versus five can no longer
hold
og in the upper bracket finals breakdown
lgd
ot are going to the grand finals for the
second year in a row
by the time the finals rolled around it
felt as if
resistance was futile as if og's caustic
combination of fire
flowers and friendship simply couldn't
be stopped i can't believe what we're
seeing in this game for
oh gee you thought you saw it all again
you've done a show
tv
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
no-till has won four majors two ti's
back to back and stands as the single
highest earning competitor in the
history of esports
he is in no one certain terms the single
greatest player his game has ever seen
he's also
the sweetest
never never do this to yourself again
you're the [ __ ] best man
you're the absolute best man never
thought yourself again
yeah remind remind me later this year we
all do it
i'll be going through it and once it's
my turn you'll be there
there's a lot to og's story innumerable
things that make it
one of if not the most miraculous tales
in esports
but at the center of it all is no talent
the one who suffered more than anyone
else
before this tournament um things were a
bit
dark my dog had died and
yeah it was it was really rough for a
couple weeks sorry my self-esteem was
pretty low and
over here who took all of the
[ __ ] that the world had to throw at him
in stride
which shoulder is it man what this one
i don't remember i think it must be this
one it must be this one
the man who deigned to have a vision to
stay true to it even as it crumbled
before him
the man who watched as it came to
fruition in the greatest way imaginable
you win as a team and you lose as a team
if you look at a game like
like this i also think you get to enjoy
it more the one dude in professional
gaming who made the silly
stupid decision to believe in friendship
and who wasn't just rewarded for it but
deified
you're [ __ ] blessed even history the
best in your story
and you are friends that's the most
important of your friends imagine
no tail is everything that dota should
be a flower
but also a rainbow and the river the
biggest
of daddies the manifestation of all
perfection and
i wanna i don't [ __ ] know you are
[ __ ] perfect mate [ __ ]
perfect
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages